bonsoir à toutes et à tous le 17
septembre 2010 est à lima au pérou
le comité international olympique
dévoilera le nom de la ville qui recevra
les jeux olympiques de 2024
paris est candidate et se place parmi
les favoris
ces jeux concerne particulièrement les
saint quentinois puisque trois sites du
territoire
le vélodrome le golf national et la
colline de la revanche à elancourt ont
été retenues dans le dossier de
candidature de la ville lumière
si 60% des français se disent plutôt
favorables à la tenue de ces jeux à
paris d'autres s'y opposent fermement
alors si les olympiques auront ils des
conséquences positives sur saint quentin
en yvelines en termes de retombées
économiques d'emploi de rayonnement de
l'agglomération encore sur le
développement du sport local des travaux
d'aménagement sont ils à prévoir dans
les sites déjà existants de
l'agglomération en fait quel sera
l'impact sur l'environnement et le
quotidien des saint quentinois pour en
parler avec nos quatre invités autour de
la table michel auger d'abord bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes président de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines maire de
montigny le bretonneux au conseiller
départemental des yvelines jean claude
de david douillet pardon vous êtes
membre du bureau départemental
europe ecologie les verts non ce moment
bonsoir monsieur euro dont vous êtes
président du comité départemental
olympique et sportif des yvelines et
enfin vincent jacquet bonsoir mon sens
est directeur technique national de la
fédération française de cyclisme
on va commencer avec vous monsieur
retour avant de parler économie on va
parler de sport puisque les jeux
olympiques sont avant tout une
compétition sportive
alors qu'est ce que saint quentin en
yvelines et peut-être plus largement le
département des yvelines
on a gagné de ces jeux olympiques je
partirai plutôt sur le département
puisque le comité olympique et sportif
divine représente le mouvement olympique
pour le département je rappellerai en
quelques quelques chiffres en termes de
volume 1 million 400 mille personnes non
département sur un million quatre cent
mille personnes 400 mille licenciés
sportifs reste un des départements
qu'elle plus qu'il ya plus de
deux licenciés sportifs il ya beaucoup
de oui nous sommes bien passé si on
regarde sous cet angle là parmi ces
personnes là des personnes qui font du
sport ans avant donc il reste un million
de personnes a motivé pour développer
quelque chose dans département
l'objectif du comité départemental
olympique et sportif et de mettre en
place un réseau que nous sommes en train
de développer qui met non seulement les
sportifs mais qui rapproche avec
monsieur le maire de montigny le
bretonneux avec lequel nous avons déjà
de relations dans ce domaine toutes les
municipalités que nous avons contacté
par l'intermédiaire de l'union des
maires des yvelines tout le réseau du
sport santé afin de pouvoir développer
par des dix ont des organisations
sportives dont je vous donnerai quelques
détails tout à l'heure une motivation
pour ces 1 million de personnes qui ne
connaissent de loin que de loin le sport
voilà donc également ceux qui viendront
peut-être voir si je voulais absolument
mais la motivation consiste par ce biais
là à faire en sorte que une approche
plus sociale et disons motivante
permettent à ces personnes de découvrir
ce que sont les jeux olympiques est
peut-être allé à travers juste pour
santé vers une amélioration de leur
situation physique
alors on va continuer ce premier tour de
rêve avec vincent jacquey parler de
sport toujours qu'est ce que le cyclisme
français à gagner de ce genre de
l'impliquer puis le vélodrome aussi qu'
à saint-quentin-en-yvelines ans je crois
quand on parle jeux olympiques une fois
tous les quatre ans et c'est la force
d'un rêve c'est le slogan de paris 2024
derrière c'est toute une génération de
sportifs qu'on accompagne aller vivre
une très belle aventure défendre les
valeurs de notre sport par le cyclisme
mais on peut parler des sports qui
seront représentées sur sur l'échiquier
olympiques mais effectivement porter le
bleu blanc rouge au coeur même de son
pays avec des jeux olympiques qui on
l'espère seront positionnés sur 2024 je
crois qu'il ya pas plus belle aventure
pour un sportif de haut niveau
faut quand même savoir que ces sportifs
se prépare tous les jours
certes pour les grandes compétitions
internationales telles que les
championnats du monde qu'on a pu vivre
en 2015 ici à saint quentin mais mais le
graal le graal suprême c'est le sait le
podium olympique et c'est la médaille
olympique donc effectivement pour une
génération
je crois que c'est une très belle
aventure à vivre est un rêve qui
pourrait devenir réalité et c'est
quelque chose que les jeunes cités sont
déjà en tête à 14 15 ans leur dire en
2024 il ya les jeux olympiques à à paris
pourrait en être en plus ce sera chez
vous à 50 ans c'est toute la force de
notre de notre détection c'est de donner
des objectifs et une génération
talentueuse les objectifs on a beau
parler champion d'europe champion du
monde sans s'en passer outre ces grandes
compétitions le l'objectif principal
d'une vie d'un sportif de haut niveau
sur une discipline olympique c'est des
jeux alors d'avec jutier europe écologie
et écologie les verts pardon est la
seule formation politique en france qui
s'est clairement opposé à ces jeux
olympiques
pourquoi le dire en quelques mots
pourquoi d'abord merci beaucoup
d'organiser ce débat qui montre que
justement il ya débat et que la question
ne va pas de soi avant toute chose là on
est en train de faire comme si les jeux
olympiques étaient gagnées mais pas du
tout auparavant il ya de nombreuses
étapes à passer et rien que pour passer
ces étapes
un des éléments clé c'est
l'investissement dans le seul dossier de
candidature un dossier de candidature
sérieux aujourd'hui c'est entre 100 et
120 millions d'euros de dépenses et
uniquement pour pousser sa candidature
est donc les câliner est d'autoriser le
rachat le terrain et tout ce qui va
autour de la candidature
et quand on voit tout cet argent qui qui
est investi uniquement pour une
candidature nous ce que nous disons
c'est que il serait beaucoup mieux
investi dans des équipements de de
proximité on parlait à l'instant de la
force des jeux olympiques pour
promouvoir le sport le sport pour tous
le sport populaire mais nous ce que l'on
pensé que cet argent là il sera
justement beaucoup mieux investis pour
construire des équipements de proximité
l'île de france est aujourd'hui une des
régions qui est moins bien loti en
équipements sportifs de proximité ce
dont ont besoin les gens pour s'investir
dans le sport pour découvrir de
nouvelles pratiques et pour faire passer
vers le sport des gens qui aujourd'hui
ne pratique pas c'est pas un grand
événement qui coûte d
des mille et des cents c'est au
contraire d'avoir au pied de chez eux
des équipements utiles et de proximité
et donc l'argent public qu'on pourrait
investir aujourd'hui il passe dans un
dossier de candidature ancien logis
goudé moi j'ai pas tout à fait la même
analyse bien sûr que monsieur dutil en
tout cas pour ce qui concerne le
territoire de saint quentin nous c'est
tout à fait différent puisque les
équipements existent quand on parle de
compétition dans le cadre des jo il ya
le vélodrome il ya le stade de bmx
il ya eu aussi le golf sur guyancourt et
puis le seul élément qu on aurait à
travailler différemment c'est sur la
colline à elancourt pour transformer la
piste qui existe déjà de vtt dans une
piste homologuée pour les policiers aux
dons nous on n'est pas dans les dépenses
en tout cas on sait aussi qu'il ya des
retombées économiques très très forte si
paris obtient des jo en 2024 et pour
saint quentin en yvelines aussi c'est
aussi peut-être la certitude d'avoir la
ligne 18 du métro dès 2024 portier
rapport donc on voit qui pâtira d'orly
qui ira à terme jusqu'à nanterre en
passant par le plateau par massy le
plateau de saclay saint-quentin
versailles et donc jusqu à nanterre dont
on voit aussi tout l'intérêt qu'il y a
en tout cas moi je suis un partisan
aujourd'hui
djo en 2024 ça fait cent ans que les
attentes france et je crois qu'il est
temps que nous les ayons pour vivre un
moment exceptionnel
alors au delà du moment exceptionnel est
ce que au niveau économique qui est
souvent mise en avant c'est un argument
qui est souvent utilisé par les
défenseurs ou les pros jeux olympiques
qu'est ce que ça va mener concrètement à
saint quentin en yvelines dans le
développement du sport local d'abord et
puis je ne sais pas en termes d'emploi
est-ce que ça va amener des touristes
qui vont venir consommer à saint quentin
dans les hôtels dans les restaurants etc
etc avaient chuté d'abord oui
ce que montrent les études qui ont été
faites sur les villes qui ont accueilli
récemment les jeux olympiques c'est
justement en effet très négatif
un effet repoussoir de ce grand
événement sur le tourisme local
en effet les personnes qui ont prévu de
venir habituellement sur les zones qui
accueille des événements de cette
ampleur ont plutôt tendance à différer
leur leur séjour et puis ça a un effet
également repoussoir auprès des
riverains qui voient surtout les
nuisances et puis j'aimerais revenir et
la grande soirée de cette personne qui
diffèrent leurs voyages ce sont d'autres
touristes qui viennent pour les autres
on a montrée justement à londres que on
avait une chute de la fréquentation de
40 % et que ce sont principalement les
hôtels ou à proximité immédiate des
sites qui profitent de tourisme sportif
qui vont aller dépenser sur les sites
avec souvent des commerces qui sont
dédiés au sponsoring au marketing et
c'est pas du tout le commerce local qui
qui en profite et puis j'aimerais quand
même dire un mot de ce que va coûter les
sept candidatures et si jamais elle elle
doit avoir lieu sur sur saint quentin en
yvelines
monsieur loger disait que les
équipements avaient déjà été réalisés
oui effectivement là parce qu'elle
concerne 51 8 août a fait pour pour 2012
un vélodrome a déjà été construits dont
on voit aujourd'hui le gouffre financier
qu'il représente
on cherche aujourd'hui un second souffle
et une utilisation à ce vélodrome qui a
coûté plus de 50 millions dont 40
millions d'euros d'argent public qui
coûte chaque année à l'agglomération 4 à
5 millions en fonctionnement et si on
construit on aménage de nouveau site on
va se retrouver à nouveau à devoir
entretenir des sites qui ne sont pas du
tout adaptés à la pratique du plus grand
nombre au contraire qu'ils sont adaptés
à la pratique d'un petit nombre et au
sport spectacle c'est pas du tout comme
ceux ci que nous envisageons des
investissements utiles alors dans le
sport réponse rapide de michèle dauger
puis jean-claude redonner tout
simplement savez quand on part sur des
grands équipements qu'ils soient
culturels ou sportifs on sait on sait
très bien qu'il n'ya pas une rentabilité
immédiate
il faut laisser aussi à ce vélodrome le
temps de prendre toute sa place
notamment pour des événements culturels
en tout cas le voeu le vélodrome a déjà
rempli toute sa mission au niveau de la
fédération française de cyclisme mais
sans choquer pour en parler beaucoup
mieux que moi vous rappelle qu'en 2015
nous avons accueilli les championnats du
monde sur piste et pendant quatre jours
nous avons affiché complet
donc ça a été une vraie réussite et j'ai
regardé tous les chiffres iavi bien sûr
des personnes qui ont lu du monde entier
avec rayonnement aussi économique
important puisque tous les hôtels contre
les hôtels tous les hôtels tous les
restaurants de l'agglomération affiché
complet dont je dire il peut y avoir
aussi autre chose effectivement dont
nous sommes en train de travailler avec
les responsables du vélodrome pour
donner cette nouvelle dimension en tout
cas déjà bien je peux vous donner
rendez-vous b peut-être vous pourriez
venir pour les championnats d'europe qui
auront lieu au mois d'octobre dans le
vélodrome et vous verrez que le
vélodrome a toutes les capacités à
pouvoir accueillir de grands événements
mais on travaille aussi pour avoir une
autre ambition
il ya des entreprises aussi qu'ils
organisent leurs séminaires et d'où donc
faut voir aussi tout le côté positive et
pas de regarder uniquement le côté
financier un peu négatif que vous
présentez dans un club dont justement
voulu apporter une contradiction si vous
permettez monsieur ce à travers deux
expériences personnelles que j'ai vécu
hors du lot de jeux olympiques la
première c'était pendant mes études 1
grenoble en 1968 il s'agissait des jeux
olympiques d'hiver
je peux vous dire que la ville de
grenoble dans laquelle j'ai habité
pendant les quatre ans devions suivre
quelque chose près à bénéficier très
très largement des retombées alors bien
sûr et instantanément comme dans tout
projet économique il faut atteindre le
point mort donc pendant un certain temps
il ya de la poussière sur les murs il ya
eu des personnes qui habitaient dans la
ville qui se plaignait mais quelques des
années après en particulier dans le
développement de la ville de grenoble
sud où il n'y avait pas d'habitants et
bien les bâtiments qui avait été
construit pour accueillir les sportifs
des jeux olympiques ont été mis à la
disposition de la municipalité et qui
attend avec des plans j'imagine de
rachat de tout ça est aujourd'hui de la
ville de grenoble a bénéficié de 50000
habitants de plus qui se plaisent bien
dans ce quartier deuxième expérience et
celle de londres à laquelle nous faisait
allusion ce qui se trouve que mon fils
habite l'ombre et qu avant les jeux
olympiques de 2012
nous y allions souvent on continue à y
aller et je constate que les quartiers
correspondant où il est exact monsieur
vous avez raison ça a été très difficile
pendant un certain temps mais qu'elle
compte quelle construction ne gêne pas
son implantation pendant un certain
temps du temps le temps de l'art vous
c'est le jeu de tous les travaux
rapidement pour le ramener dans tous les
goûts touche aux infrastructures lourdes
il est évident qu'on a ce genre de
conséquences par contre moi je voudrais
ajouter que sur le plan humain à travers
ce que nous développons en département à
peu de frais nous devrions apporter
beaucoup sur les populations
nous avons apporté la preuve déjà avec
monsieur laugier et je pense que nous
allons continuer nos départements ça
c'est à coup je dirais par rapport à un
coût d'infrastructure
c'est très négligeable par contre il ya
un impact sur les populations qui est
très important je crois qu'il faut voir
comme ça comme un investissement des
jeux aussi parce que je pense que certes
un dossier de candidature coûte cher
mais il faut savoir qu'il ya des de
l'emploi autour de ce dossier de
candidature et des gens qui travaillent
pour dossier de candidature pour mémoire
on est à plus de 50 personnes sur paris
2024 et qui sont en train de travailler
à temps complet donc ce sont des gens
qui sont engagés et professionnellement
dans ce dispositif là mais c'est vrai
que ça nous permet aussi de revoir
autrement la vision qu'ont à long terme
du territoire et derrière ça de pouvoir
imaginer non pas pour uniquement une
finalité de jeux olympiques mais pour
accompagner la population à bien grandir
sur l'europe et sur le long terme
le vélodrome aujourd'hui autour du
vélodrome se reconstitue tout un
dispositif lié aux transports doux aux
pratiques en famille au transport
sécurisé à la pratique ville au tout
autour de l'île de loisirs et puis
derrière l'aménagement de de la colline
elancourt qui pour nous n'a pas qu'un
but et on se tromperait si ce n'était
qu'un but que de pratique de haut niveau
la toute petite frange que l'on que l'on
perçoit aujourd'hui derrière c'est
l'aménagement d'un site vraiment dédié à
la pratique pour le plus grand nombre
je pense à l'intergénération au travail
en famille vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure du sport santé donc ne nous
bloquons pas sur la date uniquement de
2024 c'est que ce dispositif jeux
olympiques créer d'une part l'engouement
l'adhésion
mais derrière ça un investissement sur
le long terme pour accompagner les
petits minots qui sont en train de
grandir aujourd'hui tout simplement
taper du pied pour vos quêtes
écologistes c'est exactement qui vous
parle alors plus de saint quentinois qui
vont pouvoir faire plus de vélo moi je
veux bien qu'on compare la situation de
grenoble ont 68 avec celle de saint
quentin où paris aujourd'hui mais je ne
pense pas qu'elle soit réellement
similaires aujourd'hui paris et l'île de
france possède déjà des infrastructures
de transports des infrastructures
économiques des infrastructures de
touristes des infrastructures scolaires
éducative et sportive et je ne pense pas
qu'il faille attendre les jeux
olympiques comme une sorte de baguette
magique pour développer et pour
travailler sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
on lui dit que ça va être la recette
miracle pour le touriste pour le
développement économique mais que ne le
faisons nous pas dès maintenant un
budget jeux olympiques il commence à peu
près à 5 milliards d'euros celle
enveloppe initiale qui souvent avancé en
tout cas c'était ça pour londres on est
à peu près sur ce même niveau
d'investissement pour pourparlers
milliards pour nos 7 milliards pour
annoncer 15 milliards pratiquement
dépensé on est on est à peu près certain
que pour paris on va atteindre ce niveau
de dépassement qui va être couvert en
quasi totalité par la puissance publique
dans ce budget que que vous préciser ne
sont pas un plus non plus des mesures de
sécurité et ça ça a été une grande
surprise lorsque j'ai jeté un oeil dans
ce sens dans ce budget donc dire que les
jeux olympiques sont la solution miracle
pour développer les transports
l'économie
non si les financements étaient
disponibles et bien utilisons les dès
maintenant et à bon escient et pour tout
et pour tous par pour l'ordre plusieurs
études qui montrent entre 1 et 12
milliards de bénéfices qui ont été
réalisés ont dopé l'action se situe et
des méthodes utilisées charles auger 11
milliards six cent 600 me à ce jour les
retombées mais il ya d'ar toujours parce
que on voit bien que c'est un effet qui
ne s'arrête jamais et je pense que les
retombées et doit encore pendant
plusieurs années je pense pas qu'ils moi
je dire je partage pas votre vision mais
j'estime qu'elle même que les géo alors
je dis pas que c'est ce qu'il faut
absolument mais c'est un booster voilà
c'est un booster pour dynamiser un
territoire et je pense que la région ile
de france a besoin aussi de ses genoux
et d'ailleurs vous voyez bien que
aujourd'hui de nombreux élus quelque
parti que ce soit aujourd'hui s'engage
dans la dans la cordée peut-être ben oui
mais vous êtes peut-être le seul dont
voilà peut-être il faut aussi vous ont
découvert l'enfant faute évitait aussi
vous vous basez vous ferez terme aux
essais le réseau et agressions oui
d'accord mais c'est pas parce que vous
le pensez fort que vous avez raison
aussi
géant messieurs donc moi je pense que
c'est plutôt un booster est en tout cas
moi je reviens sur le territoire de
saint quentin c'est aussi un engouement
pour toute une population
je vois que dans les jambes il a du
monde 20 % du public étaient 56 doit
donc c'est quand même une grande de
grande réussite
et puis nous c'est prouvé aussi notre
capacité à accueillir de grands
événements internationaux et je pense
que c'est aussi un bien bien pour
l'ensemble du territoire et tout le
monde l'a peut en avoir des retombées
on est on était capable d'organiser les
championnats du monde de cyclisme on va
prouver qu'on est capable de faire les
championnats d'europe aussi dont sur
piste au vélodrome mais on est aussi
retenu et c'est ce qu'elle aime bien
d'être aussi vu par les grandes
autorités sportives mondiales pour
accueillir la ryder cup de golf en 2018
et là je vous rappelle ses soixante dix
mille personnes jours qui vont venir
donc aujourd'hui notre capacité à
accueillir des événements internationaux
sportifs font que 50 est aujourd'hui est
reconnue de manière internationale
témoin c'est ce qui me fait plaisir
d'autant que la population joue le jeu
et le bleu le président en parler nous
avons quand même un territoire très
sportif
je vois que de nombreux bénévoles se
sont engagés auprès de la fédération
pour être autour des grandes
manifestations c'est la même chose pour
le golf il ne manque que absolument pas
de bénévoles et je pense que alors là
l'engouement des
djo surtout les clubs sportifs fera que
ça va encore dynamiser notre politique
sportive et je me rappelle vous êtes
venu remettre à montigny il ya quelques
mois
la récompense de la ville la plus
sportive des yvelines dont je pense que
tout ceci entraîne sauna alors justement
avant de vous donner la porte
jean-claude redon nous sommes allés
demander aux saint quentinois ce qu'il
pensait de la tenue de l'organisation de
ces jeux olympiques avec notamment un
impact ici à saint quentin en yvelines
on regarde je pense que ça peut être
intéressant ça peut être une manne
financière touristique
non j'ai pas d'avis particulier
honnêtement non d'abord il ya un
vélodrome donc autant seront servis on
l'a fait autant en servir et puis ça
peut redonner un petit peu d'ambiance
dans tout ça moi je suis très bien à
écouter moi franchement pour dire la
vérité je suis pas un jeux olympiques
parce que je trouve que voulait dépenser
tout une fortune il vaut mieux donner ça
aux pauvres ça peut être que très bien
pour pour notre ville après
faut-il qu'on néglige ça peut être très
bien pour notre ville notre ville mais
faut-il qu'on est les gens clos breton
je voulais ajouter c'est que sur le plan
de la motivation des habitants du
département
nous venons et on en veut rencontrer
beaucoup des deals comme vous nous avons
vu beaucoup de personnes dans des
entreprises
nous avons mis en place un projet qui
s'appelle l'exposition pardon
l'exposition qui concerne la l'ensemble
d'une approche des jeux olympiques qui
va faire le tour du département
partout nous avons présenté notre projet
en des entreprises et les collectivités
locales à des entités sociologique
partout nous avons reçu en a pas un
accueil très positif sur la proche de
nous présentons l'objectif étant de
motiver à travers les jeunes
immédiatement at a pris à partie par la
proche unss usep tu donc dans les écoles
une je rencontre bientôt l'inspecteur
d'académie à ce sujet nous devons par ce
biais la motiver les personnes dans les
écoles à travers les écoles et leurs
enfants les enfants les familles pour
que l'ensemble du tissu du département
soit arrosé je dirais pas recette à
cette approche d'une exposition
itinérante a lancé voilà je vais vous
faire justement commenté c'est un
sondage qui est paru aujourd'hui donc
pour le parisien sondages aux hawks à
71% des français alors les champions et
de 1012 personnes qui ont été sondés
71% des français pensent que c'est juste
de la pid contribuera au rayonnement de
la france dans le monde
donc des français plutôt favorable à ces
jeux olympiques
vincent jacquey prévient qu'on accuse
effectivement cet engouement populaire
qui est nécessaire incontournable pour
porter une candidature parce que c'est
de ça dont on parle c'est la force d'un
pays qu'on a vécu pour les championnats
du monde que j'ai pu suivre en tout cas
en 2015 oui ou non aujourd'hui si ces
aventures ce que je prends vraiment ce
mot aventure
au sens noble du terme sont fédératrices
engagent des personnes dans une belle
aventure derrière ça nous on le voit ce
vélodrome président logis disais tout à
l'heure
faut laisser un peu de temps pour qu'il
prenne sa place pour qu'il prenne toute
sa mesure je le vois tous les jours de
plus en plus d'écoles de plus en plus de
pratiquants le matin dans les créneaux
7h 9h de plus en plus de pratiquants le
soir ça tourne ça vit ça partage tout ça
est le propre vraiment d'une d'une
aventure qui est en train de bien
prendre alors on se serait trompé si on
avait visite le haut niveau je crois
qu'aujourd'hui je prends d'une
expression de rugbyman l'essai il est en
train d'être transformée parce que la
piste de bmx ce soir il ya énormément de
gamins dessus avec les parents il ya une
vie associative qui s'installe et très
concrètement on est en train aujourd'hui
de voir évoluer ce vélodrome et dans les
prochaines années je pense que ça va ça
va faire partie d'un patrimoine
semble-t-il logique de la population
saint-quentinoise et ce patrimoine c'est
pour nos générations futures aussi le
gage d'une d'une proposition sportif qui
est riche et et ça c'est important de le
préciser
davet du tiers des personnes interrogées
par les équipes de tes fils disait si un
vélodrome qui existent pourquoi ne pas
l'utiliser
alors moi j'aimerais revenir avant tout
sur l'étude d'opinion que le
porte-parole de nous proposer avec 70%
des personnes
alors ce sens est un sondage csa leur
spirale je pense que si on le faisait au
niveau de l'île de france on serait
quelques pourcentages en dessous encore
et ça c'est quelque chose de tout à fait
caractéristique à 8 ans de l'échéance
systématiquement on a vu des populations
parce qu'elle n'avait pas tous les
éléments du débat se déclarer
globalement plutôt favorable sans avoir
un avis très tranché et puis on voit en
général répondent par ignorance du du
contenant mais j'ai une question à une
personne elle ne peut répondre que si
elle a tous les éléments du débat un
débat c'est contradictoire il faut des
informations précises que aujourd'hui on
n'a pas encore eu l'occasion de
transmettre très largement et on voit se
dégrader l'image de ce genre de grands
événements au fur et à mesure que la
date approche et plus particulièrement
dans les populations de la région qui
sont concernés et moi j'ai
à peu près aucun doute sur le fait que
si jamais par il était retenu pour 2024
la cote de popularité des jeux
olympiques diminuerait jusqu'à quelque
chose comme 30% ce qui était le cas à
londres lors de la dernière édition des
jeux olympiques parce que effectivement
les gens se rendent compte que il s'agit
de dépenser des sommes faramineuses pour
promouvoir effectivement le sport de
haut niveau bien entendu mais ce n'est
pas la seule manière de le promouvoir et
les retombées sur le sport le sport
populaire et les équipements de
proximité
elles sont extrêmement faibles et sur le
vélodrome en question alors la question
qui était posée enfin la réflexion qui
était faite par le vélodrome et il va
coûter effectivement jusqu'à 40 millions
de temps derrière latvala il a désormais
effectivement et on se retrouve avec la
problématique est posée systématiquement
par ce grand genre de grands équipements
qui sont là pour faire rayonner une
ville mais qui n'apportent pas
réellement de services à la population
et il faut surtout éviter désormais d'en
construire d'autres d'investir à nouveau
dans des équipements qui vont nous
rester sur les bras et il faut
absolument diversifier effectivement
usage de ce vélodrome qui je le rappelle
coûte aux saint quentinois 4 à 5
millions tous les ans en fonctionnement
et c'est une structure
il faut pas mentir aux gens qui n'a pas
vocation à être rentable un jour on dit
il faut laisser le temps à cette équipe
en de prendre sa place dans le paysage
certes mais il ne sera jamais rentable
pour vous ne sera jamais rentable et
c'est bien ce sera également votre
conclusion d'un mi juillet je me
répondre si c'est vrai que une équipe
bon public il est rarement rentable ce
qu'on pourrait dire la même chose avec
la philharmonie sur paris on pourrait
dire la même chose avec le théâtre de
saint quentin
je peux vous lister tous les grands
équipements publics il y en a aucun qui
ait qui a été rentable en tout cas il y
avait un manque évident et ça veut dire
c'est est reconnu par tout le monde
il manquait un vélodrome digne de ce nom
en france vont nous avons aujourd'hui
nous la chance de la voir sur notre
territoire est en tout cas je vous donne
rendez-vous dans quelques années et on
verra à ce moment là qui a raison de
nous deux non je pense que on est en
train de voir une appropriation de ce
vélodrome de plus en plus évidente par
la population 5 1 de noise et même au
delà puisqu'il ya de grands événements
aussi qu'ils sont qui sont organisés et
moi dont je suis persuadé en plus que
aux bonbons ou les jo seront là parce
que je suis convaincu qu'il nous faut
les jo en france et ne voulait jouer sur
et comme je disais tout à l'heure nous
au moins on n'a pas à construire puisque
les équipements sont déjà existants
voyez donc on va coûter moins cher dans
le dossier de candidature jean-claude
redon voilà je pense que la preuve il a
tu re de paris 2002 22000 24-20 doit
apporter va apporter sur la population
de non non sportives aujourd'hui déserts
des actes d apport énorme que nous ne
mesurons pas quand on parle avec
aujourd'hui avec les médecins par
exemple qui travaillent sur le
département dans le cadre des relations
nous avons avec le corps médical
nous approchons avec des méthodes
nouvelles avec des jeunes qui ont été
formés pour ça qu'ils vont dans les
landes dans les différents lieux où nous
organisons des de l'information nous
attaquons les quartiers en politique de
la ville nous fûmes montons des à des
méthodes des méthodologies de
développement du sport
les familles se rapproche elles viennent
faire du sport à des moments où à
l'époque nous n'avions pas je parle du
rugby je m'occupe du rugby dans le
département nous avons nous avons
aujourd'hui des familles familles qui
viennent faire du rugby à 5
pourquoi parce qu'on a on a expliqué ce
genre de choses et c'est parti d'où ces
parties du championnat du monde mais qui
a lu en france il ya quelques années où
nous avons vu l'augmentation monsieur le
dtn delà du cyclisme me faisait allusion
aux erreurs augmentation dans les grands
événements ça a été le cas pour le rugby
nous avons eu en france une poussée très
importante et ça va se produire pareil
derrière jeux olympiques et vous avez
encore une conséquence immédiate sur je
pense sur les populations
à partir du moment où nous développons
quelque chose pour elle je crois que
c'est ça qui est important
vraiment parce que le haut niveau il
faut travailler aussi sur la base et
nous le faisons avec les collectivités
locales
voilà c'est un autre français rugbyman
qui va conclure en 10 secondes vraiment
en retard
cette prétention la prenons ça comme un
héritage pour nos générations futures
sans équipement pas de développement et
sipa développement une population ou une
dynamique qui se meurt donc je le vois
tous les jours à saint quentin au
vélodrome là où je travaille
le nombre de gens qui courent qui sont
en poussette en famille sport-santé tout
ça doit parler c'est l'héritage de nos
jeux
merci à tous les cas pour ce débat
passionnant vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission sur le site de téléphiles
www.tv fil 78 points comme bonne soirée
à tous